so Fox News host Jesse Waters has really
outdone even the low standards he set
for himself with a new baseless
conspiracy theory and just wild
allegation against Joe Biden in his
latest unhinged rant on Fox News Waters
is now claiming that the FBI
installed Joe Biden as president as a
quote intelligence operation after
blackmailing Biden for a decade with a
fabric I guess with a fabricated
allegation of bribery now this is this
is crazy for a fox host to say you know
we see this stuff on other platforms
real America's voice Newsmax those types
of places we sometimes see this level of
unhinged and baseless conspiracy theory
on Fox News presented by a guest and the
the host will usually kind of play a
objective reporter but from a fox Host
this is actually pretty wacky stuff so
let's take a listen to this and where
this why Jesse Waters is doing this
where it's surface I don't know maybe
it's
um a response to some kind of hunger
from the Fox News audience for some new
red meat conspiracy about Joe Biden I
don't know but let's listen to it now
once you cover politics for a while you
realize the presidents aren't the
powerful ones it's the people who put
the presidents in the White House
they're the powerful ones ah that we've
always known politicians are puppets Joe
Biden confessed it to a group of kids
I heard you had to get back to the Oval
Office and by the way the one thing I
thought when I got to be president I get
to give orders
but I take more orders than I ever did
and you're right by the way like as if
that's a Smoking Gun
that to me it's just as easily could
mean I work for the people who voted for
me right I take orders from the voters
which sounds to me very much like
something Biden would say or simply
joking about the number of Demands and
people that make demands of a president
like the idea of that is a Smoking Gun
for this wild conspiracy is laughable
but let's continue
so that he can take orders not give them
Joe bidesmen groomed his whole career to
take orders and now that he's literally
slept his way to the top they won't let
him go anywhere what the FBI put their
guy in the White House you think we're
just gonna like let voters decide if he
should serve four more years we can't
afford to take that risk
Joe Biden's been an intelligence Ops
since he was vice president one of the
FBI's top informants a guy with
impeccable credentials a great track
record reported an allegation that Joe
Biden took a 5 million dollar bribe
right under Barack Obama's nose from a
foreign National in exchange for a
policy decision that is not true they've
been blackmailing jobs well you know I
think I should be more accurate there's
no evidence at this time that that's
true you know it's sort of like when
people said oh hydroxychloroquine
it's not at initially at least it wasn't
it doesn't work for covet it's right now
there's no evidence it doesn't work for
covet maybe in the future there will be
such evidence there wasn't by the way
Biden with this for a decade well until
a whistleblower came forward and now
James Comer wants a document released to
Congress and the FBI is caught in a
cover-up yeah the the That's The
Whistleblower we can't find we don't
know where the where where the
Whistleblower is this this is
particularly absurd and irresponsible
now I know many of you are probably
saying David you know they do those
circus Revival things on the weekends
and they say stuff like this all the
time you go on to these Conspiracy
YouTube channels and they say stuff like
this on the time they do this is Fox
News and this is a different level of
crazy it's a different level of
irresponsible it's also dangerous and
Incredibly divisive because underlying
this if I give you the conspiracy theory
that the Earth is flat okay I'm not
undermining the legitimacy of our
democracy
you you could say well if you think it
should be taught in school
just saying I think the Earth is flat or
you know there were two people involved
in the killing of JFK instead of one or
some it's not directly undermining
our democracy and how presidents are
elected in the rule of law but when you
say the FBI put Biden in as an
intelligence operation it had nothing to
do with the way people voted your fuel
fueling paranoia and anger and we know
that Trump supporters already had enough
paranoia and anger to do what they did
on January 6th based on being unable or
unwilling to accept the reality of the
defeat of Donald Trump they also
distract from real issues like whatever
right I mean quite literally any issue
would be more important than the the
conspiracy theory that the FBI uh
operated uh did an operation in which
they put Biden in the White House and
and really it wasn't Biden who won it
might have been Trump but it didn't
matter because the FBI set it all up
could be climate change could be the
economy it could be anything quite
literally anything would be more
important than this and of course if you
say does Waters have evidence to back
this up he doesn't what he's referring
to is the same Anonymous sources that
Trump and others regularly attack and
say we should be listening to dubious
documents that don't even say the things
they claim they say maybe his
imagination maybe his desire for
something like this to be true or his
desire for Ratings or I don't know and
of course nowhere in there is the fact
that the numbers with which Joe Biden
won you know more than seven million
votes obviously at the Electoral level
it depended on a far smaller number of
votes just like Trump's Victory depended
in 2016 an election which at each
individual state was certified and
despite more than 60 cases and the other
thing you would think that in that
investigation the auditing and the
forensics and looking for barbecue sauce
on ballots and fibers and all these
different things
if this was actually an FBI op there
would be some evidence of that there
would be and in fact there is not so I
don't have to tell you that Waters is
not a journalist he actually you know
I'm super clear on my show I'm not a
journalist I do commentary opinion and
Analysis this here I'm not doing
original reporting we look at reporting
and we discuss it we analyze and I give
my opinion that's what this is take it
or leave it okay I'm not doing what your
local news reporter does on Fox news
they deliberately blur these lines and
even though Waters sort of presents
himself like he's reporting news to you
he's not a journalist and he's not a
reporter he's a propagandist and he
regularly tells lies promulgates
disinformation all in service of the
right-wing agenda that Fox News has made
their money on he's not interested in
truth he's not interested in facts he's
interested in ratings and creating fear
and scapegoating which is the way that
Fox News Works to serve their pockets
not to serve the public interest and
maybe to serve his ego as well I would
probably say that's a factor too
one of our sponsors is short form short
form makes the world's best guides to
non-fiction books and not only does
short form Summarize each non-fiction
book itself into key points that you can
cover in just a few minutes they have
all sorts of interactive exercises to
help you apply the ideas to what you've
read to retain more the guide to each
book also includes intellectual insights
comparing and contrasting the book to
other prominent books about the same
topic so that you can contextualize the
book and understand the controversies
and the disagreements they also have
books across every non-fiction genre
from economics and politics to science
and health I was recently checking out
James clear's Atomic habits on short
form of course they have the guide but
they also have highlights they also
include other similar books about habits
and developing a routine with
differences and similarities super super
useful and a lot more than just a
summary of of the book there are new
guides and articles released every week
and short form is giving my audience a
free trial plus 25 off a subscription
which is a fifty dollar value so for the
price of a book per month you get access
to thousands go to shortform.com Pacman
the link is down below